a Coast Guard crew searches for a boater
who radioed in an unusual call
he reported his location was inside the
sea wall near the dock wise in its 15
million-dollar cargo the coast guard
vessel is armed with the latest
technology that will help them find the
mysterious boat we can use a direction
finder they talk on the radio for a long
enough period of time we can look at our
direction finders see what his bearing
is relative to us it sounds like he's
right outside la gate right here and if
he is anywhere near the gate we should
think we should get a visual on it
pretty soon
the elusive voter contacts the Coast
Guard once again this is a Coast Guard
on channel 12 go ahead
we're in statements in here
something's not right if he's inside the
harbor the Coast Guard should be able to
spot him now he's thinking safe and
secure and San Pedro Harbor
as the cleanse approached the bridge the
Coast Guard continues searching for the
voter if he is safely more there are
three possible marina areas where he
could be docked at any moment he could
decide to move into the channel and into
the dock wise path what is your location
you know your exact location right now
so you've already come inside to the
breakwall effingham 050
our vows yeah
it's not their guy he's still out there
somewhere
then another boat appears on their radar
just 500 yards away
as the doc wise moves down the channel
robina discovers the bridge isn't his
only obstacle la pilots doctors breast
10 we're just about a beam of birth to
30 now and there's a crane of still down
in china shipping give them a call see
if they can pick it up steady Thank You
doc his wrist in the crane poses a major
problem for rubino maneuvering this 11
ton ship down the narrow channel is
difficult enough rubino needs to begin
his turn while under the bridge if he
swings too wide the crane and lowered
boom arm could smash together here's the
cranes of China shippings birth and you
can see our cranes and it looks pretty
close there
hey three well we're down to about the
last 500 yards and we're we're creeping
ahead at about three knots out of fast
fast walk the problems keep mounting for
rubino traffic on the Vincent Thomas
bridge hasn't been stopped so they will
stop the traffic but look like they're
still going stop to stop the engine doc
express to port Police okay we're
proceeding the dock wise is at the
bridge on time but traffic still streams
across a crane boom is down
and a rogue sailor still eludes the
Coast Guard what is your location you
know your exact location right now that
rabito back on I don't know it doesn't
look that good from here see